madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue en
direct sur le plateau de la voie libre
en Bourgogne aujourd'hui nous allons
nous intéresser au sort des entreprises
au terme d'une semaine de mobilisation
lancée par le MEDEF par la CGPME et par
l'UA les trois principales organisations
patronales pour en parler sans réunies
sur ce plateau pierre à Bouziane bonjour
vous êtes député de la Côte-d'Or depuis
des socialiste Jean-Paul Barbet bonjour
vous êtes président du Medef de
Saône-et-Loire Alain Raymond bonjour
bonjour secrétaire départementale du
Parti communiste dans l'Yonne et puis
Benoît Villot bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le président de la CGPME en Côte-d'Or à
la maison je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez poser vos questions directement à
nos invités via notre site internet
bourgogne.france3.fr via Twitter hashtag
lvl Bourgogne ou AT3 Bourgogne et enfin
sur notre page facebook
Jean-Paul Barbet pourquoi avoir organisé
maintenant cette semaine de mobilisation
alors vous dites que ça fait 30 ou 40
ans que les politiques ne vous
conviennent pas pourquoi maintenant
écoutez depuis 40 ans que ce soit de
droite comme de gauche l'entreprise est
considérée comme une variation
d'ajustement au déficit de l'État je
crois que c'est une constatation qu'on
ne peut pas
ignorer
il est grand temps que l'entreprise soit
considérée comme une des seules
solutions au développement de notre pays
l'entreprise est la seule effectivement
aujourd'hui à dégager des richesses
elle sur qu'elle soit écoutée
et qu'elle soit rentable surtout ce qui
permettra effectivement nous
gouvernements d'avoir un socle suffisant
pour obtenir un état généreux qui peut
redistribuer mais on en trouve par
exemple votre votre vice-président le
vice-président du medefroid route des
yeux qui disait que il y avait des
efforts sincères du gouvernement en ce
moment faveur de la compétitivité alors
je n'ai pas que les il y a des efforts
de la part de ce gouvernement
à nous donner des espoirs
avec le cice avec le pack de
responsabilité le cice est en place on
en parlera tout à l'heure parce que j'ai
des chiffres quand même assez importants
à dire pour savoir que ceci n'est
malheureusement pas
le résultat qu'on estompait le pack de
responsabilité aujourd'hui le pack de
responsabilité les entreprises veulent
bien effectivement négocier des efforts
mais faut-il encore qu'ils soient en
place aujourd'hui il va être en place en
15 2016-2017 et aujourd'hui il y a rien
il y a rien de très concret là-dessus on
va essayer aujourd'hui
13 millions de cice pour 2013
il y a qui est devenu d'ailleurs 12
millions il y a 8 millions 3 qui étaient
éligibles et on a versé aujourd'hui 5
millions de si on parle du cice moi je
dirais que le cice est peut-être une
mauvaise interprétation que on aurait pu
faire on aurait pu dire on descend les
charges de temps pour toutes les
entreprises qui se soit les entreprises
du CAC 40 de des PMI des PME des
artisans des commerçants des des
professions libérales et ça mon confrère
pour vous en parle plus que moi on
aurait pu effectivement avoir une
égalité pour toutes les entreprises
aujourd'hui les entreprises ont un
ras-le-bol effectivement d'une
méconnaissance je suis désolé de vous le
dire d'une méconnaissance du monde
politique vis-à-vis des entreprises
voilà justement voilà donner la parole à
carabouzian méconnaissance pour vous
cette semaine d'action elle est
incompréhensible comme l'a dit Stéphane
Le Foll cette semaine si vous permettez
je vais je vais vous lire un court
extrait je suis je suis même très
opposée à ce mouvement en termes de
communication ces catastrophique s'il y
en a bien qui ont bénéficié des mesures
de ce gouvernement ce sont les
entreprises et les entrepreneurs
descendre dans la rue pour dire que cela
ne suffit pas est un peu indécent par
rapport à toutes les catégories de
personnes qui ont des problèmes en ce
moment en 2014 c'est la première fois
qu'un gouvernement a fait baisser les
prélèvements après des années et des
années d'augmentation il faut s'en
féliciter ce n'était pas le cas des
débuts du gouvernement héros bref et une
autre phrase
la France et le paradis fiscal pour la
création d'entreprise ce sont deux
phrases ce sont deux phrases de chefs
d'entreprise la première c'était Sylvain
auréby président directeur général du
groupe Orientis et la deuxième c'est
celle de Xavier Niels alors tout ça pour
dire que ça a été dit je le reconnais
mais vraiment de façon très feutrée on
reconnaît que ce gouvernement fait
quelque chose mais on voit pas les
résultats je voudrais d'abord avant de
d'aller dans ce sens là
reprendre votre phrase le gouvernements
utilise l'entreprise comme variable
d'ajustement pour prélever
je vous apprendrai rien quand vous
regardez le budget de l'État
60% du budget de l'État ce sont des
impôts indirects c'est à dire ce qu'on
ne voit pas ceux qui sont soi-disant
indolore la TVA et toutes les taxes sur
les produits pétroliers et l'impôt sur
les sociétés 40% donc là je voudrais
quand même qu'on puisse nuancer le
gouvernement donne des espoirs le
résultat
les résultats tardent à venir juste une
petite parenthèse le temps politique et
le temps économique n'est pas le même
quand vous prenez des décisions il y a
quand même un certain nombre de passages
obligés
au niveau du Parlement du Conseil
constitutionnel il y a tout un travail
qui se fait et bien sûr
et je le comprends tout à fait cependant
dire que le cice n'a pas de résultats
aujourd'hui des chiffres tons 2013 pour
2013 certains entreprises l'ont touché
on y viendra s'il vous plaît aussi plus
précisément là déjà un petit mot de
passe pour la méconnaissance des
entreprises
de la part des politiques je sais pas si
vous avez déjà été auditionné par par
des politiques il y a les politiques qui
sont pour un certain nombre d'entre eux
en contact direct et pas seulement à
l'Assemblée parce que nous avons des
permanences et nous en recevons tous les
jours il y en a qui sont qui ont la
culture de l'économie aussi
non mais je vous le dis parce que il y a
et en plus je connais parmi mes
collègues des gens très brillants en la
matière et c'est un procès que vous
faites pour justifier que on ne
prendrait pas les bonnes décisions qui
iraient dans le sens que vous le
souhaitez et moi je trouve ça
inacceptable inacceptable
j'imagine que vous ne l'entendez pas de
cette oreille Benoît absolument pas j'ai
entendu des choses auxquelles je vais
répondre parce que c'est ça m'a fait
sourire évidemment le paradis pour les
entreprises fiscales en France il y a un
article récemment dans la presse qui
vient de paraître cette préparation
d'entreprise
l'enfer l'enfer fiscal en Europe pour
les PME la France
un résumé 66% du résultat net des
entreprises en France en termes
d'imposition 48% en Allemagne 33% au
Royaume-Uni donc effectivement si ça
c'est le paradis je me demande
effectivement où elle enfer parce que là
il y a un vrai vrai problème quand je
parle quand vous parlez de la
mobilisation des chefs d'entreprise on a
une première mobilisation de premier
décembre avec la CGPME seule ensuite
avec le Medef et l'UPR cette semaine
cette mobilisation vous savez les chefs
d'entreprise patron de PME ils ont pas
l'habitude de descendre dans la rue la
dernière fois c'était il y a 10 ans pour
les 35 heures donc on n'est pas des
habitués ni des coutumiers du fait quand
on le fait c'est qu'il y a une vraie
situation d'urgence aujourd'hui 30% de
défaillance supplémentaires d'entreprise
au tribunal de commerce de Dijon dans le
premier semestre 2014 vous n'êtes pas
censé l'oublier des défaillances veut
dire effectivement qu'il y a des
conditions pour exercer le métier de
chef d'entreprise qui deviennent
complètement obsolètes aujourd'hui
clivez également c'est pas une bonne
chose nous on va pas on n'est pas contre
ni avec on est avec les salariés c'est
aujourd'hui l'intérêt de l'entreprise
est le même intérêt pour les salariés on
n'est pas en train de prendre des
postures qui sont des postures de nantis
comme j'ai pu l'entendre qui viennent
manifester des mauvais chefs
d'entreprise non non aujourd'hui il y a
des chefs d'entreprise qui viennent on
entendu aussi qu'on faisait de la
politique alors on fait de la politique
oui alors je vais vous répondre si
effectivement défendre les PME c'est
faire de la politique on va continuer en
faire et longtemps mais c'est apolitique
notre notre mouvement il est
complètement impolitique il est orienté
pour l'intérêt des PME PMI et de ses
salariés indirectement quant aujourd'hui
vous parlez de bien-être des entreprises
un ben je vais vous donner deux chiffres
qui vont vous laisser certainement
certainement à réfléchir sur le
bien-être des entreprises entre 2004
et 2014 le le la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises tous secteurs confondus en
France c'est à dire la marge et par
marge je vais tout de suite faire une
interprétation faut pas confondre marge
et résultat net parce que la marge sert
à couvrir les charges et le résultat
c'est la différence entre marge et
charge donc cette
plante dans certains journaux à 13h ou
on confond marge et résultats c'est
absolument pas la même chose entre 2004
et 2014 la marge des entreprises a perdu
10% on est passé en France de 38% à 28%
et en même temps les prélèvements donc
l'impôt entre 2004 et 2014 lui il a il
est passé de 37% à 44%. donc quand on
dit qu'il y a une réduction de
l'imposition sur les entreprises ça me
laisserait terminer juste sur une
dernière chose
effectivement les courbes se croisent
c'est à dire un chiffre d'affaires en
baisse une marge qui diminue et des
charges qui augmentent
au bout d'un moment quand les courses se
croisent c'est le tribunal de commerce
c'est la liquidation le RJ et on enlève
de la richesse aux entreprises donc de
la rémunération salariée nous on n'est
pas opposé et on est même favorable
contrairement à certains de nos
collègues mais il faut qu'il y ait des
différences on pense aussi que
l'imposition sur les ménages doit être
revue également sur les classes moyennes
qui sont le plus touchés aujourd'hui par
cette hausse d'impôt parce qu'il y en a
eu aussi sur les ménages cette année et
qu'effectivement l'entreprise et les
ménages doivent être alléger pour qu'un
cercle vertueux de l'économie reprenne
de la consommation et les entreprises en
bonne santé voilà à la raison alors vous
je dis vous un peu Parti communiste
organisé une semaine une contre semaine
à d'actions de mobilisation face à la
mobilisation des patrons ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que vous n'acceptez
pas que les patrons puissent exprimer
eux aussi leur mécontents ils peuvent
s'exprimer ils ont largement de quoi
faire pour s'exprimer par exemple après
aujourd'hui c'est à 90 % et tenu par des
grands groupes financiers donc il y a
pas de problème
le Medef sur le sous l'impulsion du
Medef surtout cette semaine ils ont
voulu taper du point sur la table et les
deux points sur la table parce que
premièrement ils ont déjà obtenu pas mal
de choses depuis 2012 le président qui
était l'ennemi de la finance a changé
casaque et ils obtiennent et ils vont
obtenir à travers les ordonnances par
exemple qui vont être discuter la
semaine prochaine du ministre de
l'économie ils obtiennent beaucoup de
choses depuis 2012
il continue ils en veulent plus ça me
paraît tout à fait naturel quand
quelqu'un obtient à chaque fois ce qu'il
veut bah il dit on va peut-être en
obtenir plus le gouvernement a décidé
devant les pseudo bonnets rouges les
pigeons c'est ça c'était les pigeons à
l'époque donc monsieur cattaz
aujourd'hui dit allons plus loin le
problème c'est que
j'entendais monsieur tout à l'heure je
suis d'accord avec lui sur une chose
l'entreprise des doigts dégager des
richesses ça c'est une
dividendes une évidence mais cette
richesse c'est pour faire quoi est-ce
que c'est pour augmenter 30% les
dividendes comme ça s'est vu cette année
où est-ce que c'est pour donner du
salaire de faire de l'investissement
aujourd'hui les salaires sont bloqués
l'investissement est au plus bas donc où
va cette richesse ça c'est une des
questions et moi je suis pas contre le
fait que l'entreprise fasse des
richesses mais où elle va c'est la
répartition de cette richesse là après
qui m'est préoccupe quant à la
connaissance des entreprises là c'est
totalement absurde les entreprises ont
des à côté nous aussi hommes politiques
moi hier matin j'étais à la porte de
chez Freud il y a quelques semaines
j'étais devant chez cycly à
Saint-Florentin pourquoi parce que moi
j'aime les entreprises aussi et je suis
là pour les défendre et défendre leur
existence c'est donc on soutenant les
salariés et en voulant défendre la
présence de cycly qui va partir en
Pologne que je dis qu'il faut les
entreprises et que j'aime les
entreprises
mais on a le même problème qui se pose
aujourd'hui avec de graves inquiétudes
sur Auxerre avec frého qui va être
racheté par des financiers polonais qui
vont prendre toute la mécano soudure et
l'emporter l'emmener en Pologne ce qui
veut dire et c'est la grande crainte
qu'on oublie salariés que une fois que
la mécano soudure sera là-bas et bien
l'électricité les pneus les enfin tout
le reste qui habillent bien évidemment
la plateforme et bien risque de
disparaître donc nous connaissons
l'entreprise nous connaissons les
préoccupations de salariés nous
connaissons aussi les préoccupations de
certains entrepreneurs mais nous
connaissons aussi la richesse de ceux
qui dans le CAC 40 et ailleurs font des
fortunes considérables je prends un
exemple simplement on y reviendra
total paye 8 % d'impôts sur les et sur
les bénéfices la PME on paye 33
j'aimerais mettre un point précis en
France vous parlez du CAC 40 il y a 40
entreprises comme le nom l'indique car
entreprise qui sont des TI et des
grandes entreprises et vous avez 2
millions d'entreprises des PME des PME
des artisans des commerçants et des
professions libérales qui font le tissu
économique
pour vous c'est pas tout enfin il y a
que 40 entreprises au CAC 40 forcément
mais derrière il y a 1000 entreprises
grosses entreprises qui font 50% du PIB
écouter
on parlait des des cadeaux puisque en
réalité vous ne parlez encore de cadeau
que j'entends répéter sans arrêt 14
entreprises depuis 40 ans depuis 40 ans
il y a 30 milliards d'impôts
supplémentaires il y a un code du
travail qui est passé de 300 pages avec
300 sans emploi ce que j'aime pas dire
le mot chômeur il est passé à 3000 pages
avec 3 de son emploi alors en plus avec
une complication de contraintes de
règlement absurde alors si vous dites
que effectivement l'entreprise vous
aimez l'entreprise Jean-Claude encore
des mots d'amour on a entendu Manuel
Valls qui aime l'entreprise vous aimez
l'entreprise c'est bien mais j'aimerais
bien que vous confrères en politique ben
effectivement consomme ce mariage
c'était bien on a des propositions
effectivement aimer l'entreprise c'est
une chose et les les belles déclarations
nous on est preneur je rebondis sur ce
que vous disiez rapidement 95% des
entreprises sont des PME évidemment il y
en a qui représentent 50% du PIB c'est
pas nous 80 90% de l'emploi aussi c'est
les PME elle rémunir le travail et pas
le capital celle-là et donc
effectivement nous les mesures fiscales
qui sont prises en faveur du capital
nous intéressent pas on veut on veut des
vraies réductions d'impôts sur les
entreprises qui rémunèrent le travail et
si elles sont alliées de mesures en
faveur des salariés en créant plus de
richesse ça nous va très bien c'est très
distribution nous va très bien par
contre faut donner les moyens de le
faire
alors moi je voudrais sur deux remarques
qui ont été qui ont été faites et la
première
en évoquant la fiscalité des ménages qui
freinent la consommation parce
qu'aujourd'hui
on n'est pas sans savoir quand même
qu'il y a une crise profonde et que ceux
qui ferait redémarrer aussi l'activité
des entreprises c'est aussi la
consommation donc
cela ne vous aura pas échappé que
personnellement je fais partie de ceux
qui voudraient qu'il y ait une
réorientation aussi en direction des
ménages pour permettre de d'enclencher
la production et la consommation donc là
je n'ai aucun souci avec avec ça
concernant les entreprises moi je
voudrais quand même et vous êtes bien
placé pour pour être d'accord avec moi
il y a entreprise et entreprise
effectivement il y a des entreprises qui
auraient besoin
qu'on leur laisse je parle pas de
cadeaux qu'on leur laisse un certain
nombre d'avantages pour les encourager à
produire et à embaucher et je fais la
distinction entre la toute petite
entreprise la moyenne et dans les
moyennes ça peut monter quand même
jusqu'à 500 et donc ce que moi avec
certains de mes collègues avec certains
de mes collègues c'est que justement
c'est ces aides je sais que vous n'aimez
pas ce mot mais c'est ce sont des aides
quand même qui sont apportées ou en tout
cas des des remboursements de crédit
pour ce qui concerne le cice je voudrais
qu'elle soit bien
identifiée et qui vont là où on en a
besoin c'est à dire dans les toutes
petites entreprises qui irriguent nos
territoires les petites entreprises qui
sont pas qui ne sont pas confrontés à
ou en tout cas qui sont régulièrement
confrontés aux difficultés d'aller se
faire financer par les par les banques
même s'il est aujourd'hui sont
extrêmement bas j'ai rencontré des chefs
d'entreprise qui me moi j'ai un carnet
de commandes mon banquier ne me suit pas
alors pour pour
au passage vous signalerez quand même
que ce gouvernement a mis en place une
une BPI alors elle a démarré je sais la
banque publique d'investissement et ça
ne suffit qu'il faut mettre en place une
vraie banque publique c'est déjà de
l'argent pour ça c'est déjà un premier
pas et moi je tiens
un bilan de déjà son activité mais c'est
vrai que il y a un certain nombre de
choses positives qui se font il y a une
impatience et je le comprends monsieur
Bilot il y a une impatience
si vous le si vous le permettez le cice
vous le savez très bien et c'est pas
vous que je vais la prendre c'est une
économie d'impôts l'année suivante je le
sais faut-il payer de l'impôt déjà
il faut il dégager du résultat
la deuxième chose vous pouvez maintenant
vous pouvez mobiliser je connaissais
parfaitement le dispositif vous pouvez
mobiliser ce cice par BPI en
l'occurrence mais vous le mobiliser
effectivement ça a un coût en frais
financier et vous payez les charges donc
finalement c'est déjà plus le même
résultat une entreprise qui dégage peu
de cice une PME va-t-elle s'embêter à
l'immobiliser 5 10.000 euros pour payer
des charges de sucre dans un bilan ce
cice a permis de gommer la difficulté
que les entreprises rencontraient
c'est-à-dire de ne pas permettre
d'embaucher juste de gommer la crise
dans laquelle elles étaient ce cice
aujourd'hui pour les PME il sert à ça à
facialement rendre un bilan un peu plus
joli pour que le banquier soit content
en effet trésorerie immédiat 0 l'effet
trésorerie il est l'année suivante
pourquoi ça tombe pas au courant au coût
du travail réellement le coût du travail
pourquoi par exemple Auchan a touché 38
millions en 2013 et 55 millions en 2014
Sanofi qui est en train de fermer
l'entreprise à Quétigny 11 millions en
2013 et 7 millions alors bien sûr vous
êtes loin de ces chiffres là mais au nom
de quoi ces entreprises
la touche du cice quand on sait qu'elle
le place sur des des de la planète
financière un tas d'argent et on va leur
distribuer du cice moi je dis une vraie
banque publique au service des
entreprises et que ces millions là ces
milliards là pour en définitive parce
que ça va durer pendant quelques années
aille vraiment aux entreprises et que le
chef d'entreprise soit pas comme un
mendiant à les quémander parce qu'il a
un problème de trésorerie à un moment
qui va durer deux mois un emprunt de
20000 euros voilà alors
le coût du café
pour éclairer nos téléspectateurs vous
posez la question justement de Robert
qui nous demande les entreprises qui
n'ont pas signé ou la qui appartiennent
à une branche qui n'a pas signé le pack
de responsabilité est-ce qu'elle touche
le CIC est-ce qu'on peut faire un peu de
pédagogie là-dessus c'est absolument
rien à voir avec le pack de
responsabilité indépendante c'est
complètement indépendante ce pack de
responsabilité il y a des branches qui
sont en train de signer il y en a qui
ont signé oui
l'assurance
on peut pas signer effectivement avec
des partenaires sociaux comme ça à
l'aveuglette moi j'aimerais venir quand
même sur ces ice puisque il a pas les
fait escompté puisque sur les 13
milliards il y en a
55,2 milliards qui ont donné lieu à
remboursement ou à déduction donc on est
loin effectivement les de l'effet
escompté mais pour revenir à tout à
l'heure sur ces cadeaux on a nos appris
tellement de charges en l'espace de 40
ans que le fait de revenir à la nouvelle
à la normale ça serait un cadeau moi je
dis non c'est pas possible attendez vous
vous parlez de cotisations
c'est bien ça
on a des mesures qui peuvent être prises
très clairement en taxant le capital
vous le disiez tout à l'heure moi taxé
aujourd'hui la spéculation sur des
produits financiers de manière plus
forte taxer aujourd'hui la spéculation
sur les dents réalimentaires qui font
augmenter le cours des matières
premières qui sont quasiment pas taxées
plutôt que le travail ça me va très bien
mais en même temps s'attaque au coup du
travail c'est alors pourquoi
je le regrette mais mais on y travaille
juste d'un mot concernant le cice
monsieur Villot disait que effectivement
il y a un décalage ça c'est la règle
mais il y a aussi des exceptions ou une
entreprise qui aurait besoin justement
de trésorerie peut céder à une banque
et avec un couple
alors attendez justement
il faudrait retravailler sur ça mais non
attaquons nous directement
vous êtes en train de faire le procès
qui remplace aussi sur de la production
d'un dispositif à peine
on est en train de s'éclairer sur les
résultats sont bien contents de l'avoir
reçu on essaie de l'inscrire dans le
temps vous l'avez pas signé le traité
tel qu'il est alors qu'il avait promis
de leur négocier on aurait un traité
européen qui permettrait à la BCE de
prêter directement aux États et les
étapes pourraient à ce moment-là créer
une banque publique où les entreprises
pourraient venir effectivement emprunter
à des taux très faibles voire à zéro
voire un peu moins de 0 ça serait
possible et à ce moment-là il aurait pu
les difficultés qu'ils ont seulement
vous l'avez pas fait et vous ne pouvez
pas le faire dans le cadre du traité que
vous avez signé et que les Français ne
voulaient surtout pas
parce que le but c'était quand même nos
manifestations Medef UPA et CGPME vous
avez une analyse qui s'est faite
avant-hier je crois ou trois quarts des
Français sont solidaires effectivement à
cette détresse des des chefs
d'entreprise 3/4 de français
c'est-à-dire que je j'ose dire quand
même qu'une entreprise n'existe pas son
salarié et les salariés n'existent pas
son entreprise
c'est quand même en même temps il
s'étonne moi j'ai deux notamment deux
témoignages là il y a un voisin de Dijon
les problèmes ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
d'aujourd'hui qui a des problèmes c'est
bizarre qui manifestent depuis que c'est
la gauche au pouvoir et puis à Pascal je
suis troublé de voir ces derniers mois
dans la rue des pharmaciens des notaires
des huissiers des patrons que des gens
qui n'ont pas de problème de fin de mois
est-ce que par exemple et des notaires
et des patrons des patrons qui ont pas
de problème de fin de mois effectivement
la moitié des chefs d'entreprise plus de
la moitié des PME en dessous de 2500
euros net en tant que chef d'entreprise
donc effectivement ils sont riches on
peut considérer que c'est riche mais
c'est pas forcément ça reste raisonnable
pour les pharmaciens les pharmaciens
aujourd'hui nouvellement puis 4-5 ans il
y a des dépôts de bilan dans les
pharmacies non pourquoi pourquoi avec
l'arrivée des génériques ils ont perdu
aussi 10 points de marge aujourd'hui on
annonce des mesures Macron monsieur
Macron le Premier ministre annonce des
mesures comme quoi 30% des médicaments
non prescrits pour aller vers les
grandes surfaces aujourd'hui avec une
perte de marge plus l'annonce et je suis
bien placé pour en parler puisque moi
mon métier et mon enseigne nous sommes
contre cette mesure on va tuer la
pharmacie on va tuer la pharmacie parce
qu'on le fait 30 % du chiffre d'affaires
qui sont les noms prescrits à une
officine c'est tout simplement tuer la
pharmacie tuer le service ne sont pas
contre la libéralisation c'est compliqué
il faut garder il faut garder
aujourd'hui un service de pharmacie en
rural si demain vous leur enlevez 30% du
chiffre d'affaires dans une situation
qui est déjà très compliquée pour eux et
bien et bien demain ils vont ils vont
tous mourir il y aura plus de pharmacies
en campagne vous regarderez les grosses
pharmacies en centre-ville et ça sera
terminé pour les notaires et les avocats
qui manifestent aujourd'hui les avocats
et les notaires aujourd'hui on a à Dijon
350 avocats au barreau de Dijon je
prends du local sur ces 350 avocats il y
en a plus de la moitié qui sont
quasiment au SMIC pourquoi
pourquoi me posez-vous la question
est-ce que c'est une profession de nanti
non pas du tout extraordinaire
juste c'est encore en discussion c'est
comme la loi Macron pour le moment
évoluerres de choses qui ont été
avancées
ça évolue et moi j'aurais envie de dire
attendons déjà que le texte sorte qui
soit qu'il soit examiné au Parlement
avant de s'en faire une une religion
cependant là où je voudrais justement
concernant justement certaines
professions libérales parce que ce que
l'on n'a pas dit sur le cice
c'est qu'il ça et moi pour avoir
rencontré un certain nombre de de
personnes exerçant des professions
libérales je vous le dis texto il m'a
dit je ne comprends pas pourquoi j'ai
reçu du cice voilà alors là il y a un
vrai souci lui de toute façon
les chiffres pour le contraire je suis
désolé c'est quelqu'un qui est
et payer avec l'activité qu'il avait et
il avait il avait une activité qui
n'avait pas besoin de ce CIC et il a
reçu
vous êtes en train de prouver que
c'était inégal donc c'est mal ciblé
particulier
de ceux qui ont qui se sont opposés à la
à l'idée ou en tout cas à la vie
générale de mon groupe je suis toujours
socialiste mais je ne désespère pas pour
leur dire et d'ailleurs ça commence à
venir et à passer dans dans certains
esprits le cice ne doit pas être versé
sans distinction merci on continue cette
discussion dans quelques minutes mais là
il va être midi on va s'interrompre
quelques minutes pour prendre
connaissance de l'actualité régionale de
ce samedi midi le flash ce midi est
présenté par Lise Richer on se retrouve
dans 5 minutes à tout de suite